[Música]
ah
yo soy
[Música]
y yo soy
ah
soy yo a playas cielo casa plan
soy ahora
[Música]
tuya
soy un montón de cosas
antes
[Música]
mezcladas con cosas humanas
como te explico
cosas mundanas
fue un niño con antena
de hecho
[Música]
más miedo un poquito y antón rasa
claro
ahora
no se acabaron las
mirada
[Música]
algo pasó
no entendí nada
vamos decime contame
y todo lo que a vos te está pasando
porque si no cuando estando el más sola
cara
[Música]
hay que sacarlo todo afuera con la
primavera
qué quiere que adentro
mirando
a los ojos sacar lo que se puede afuera
para que adentro nazca las cosas nuevas
[Música]
soy pan soy paz soy más soy el que está
puro
no quiero
de lo que pueda sanar
hoy 77
[Música]
y tal
igual que con la más
margaritas
igual al mar
igual
la vida la dio
decime contra de todo lo que tienes
porque si no cuando esta pasión
y ahora
[Música]
hay que sacarlo todo fuera una
quiere saber
algo
fuera
[Música]
a los ojos que hagan lo que se puede
afuera
cosas
vamos decime con dame todo lo que a vos
te escapes
ahora muerta
es la de una sola hora
[Música]
nadie quiere que adentrar no se mueva
mirándose a los ojos sacar lo que se
puede afuera
[Música]
cosas
bueno
no
[Música]
bah
otras gracias
[Aplausos]
yo creo que es la alfombra la que hacen
emociones
[Música]
y como no terminar esto yo dando las
gracias
esto es violeta pana chilena
qué
se toma un ratito de su vida también
artista de mujer compositora y madre
para escribir un himno a la gratitud y a
la vida
gracias
en equipo tdt
[Música]
y a todos por estar aquí esto es gracias
a la vida de violeta
[Música]
gracias a la vida
que me ha dado tanto
[Música]
me dio dos luceros
que cuando los abro
perfecto distingo
lo negro del blanco
y en el alto cielo su fondo
y en las multitudes
al hombre
[Música]
que yo
ah
y
gracias a la vida
[Música]
que me ha dado tanto
no
[Música]
me ha dado el sonido
y él
[Música]
con las palabras
que pienso y declaró
madre amigo hermano
y luz
alumbrando
la ruta del alma
del gesto
[Música]
gracias
a la vida
que me ha dado tanto
me ha dado la risa
y me ha dado el llanto
y así yo distingo
a mitad de quiebra
[Música]
los dos materiales que forman
mi canto
y el canto de ustedes
que es en mí
mismo canto
y el canto de todos que es mi propia
boca
antón
el canto de ustedes
[Música]
qué es el mío
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
mi vida
ahora mismo las cámaras tendrían que
estar enfocando a cris es el alma de
pedir el bisbat si yo no me iba a
trabajar de aquí ya es un escalón o sea
que luego me quitó muchas gracias
esto es un privilegio estar aquí
yo estoy muy muy contenta no quiero
y despedirme sin antes cantar un tema
yo creo que no sé si mundialmente
conocido pero pero si casi
esto es te recuerdo amanda de víctor
jara
y salgo de la alfombra y encuentro la
letra
[Música]
si está comprobado
más
[Música]
te recuerdo amanda a calle mojada
corriendo a la fábrica
donde trabajan
[Música]
a sonrisa ante la lluvia en el pez
no importaba nada
y vas a encontrarte con él con él con él
con el conde
son 5 minutos
la vida es eterna
cinco minutos suena la sirena
[Música]
de vuelta al trabajo
que tu caminado lo ilumina todo
a los 5 minutos
y te hacen florecer
ah
te recuerdo al mandar la voz
yendo a la fábrica
donde trabajaba manuel
e
son
[Música]
la lluvia en él
y vas a encontrar
con él
con el poder
el contrario
[Música]
destrozado suena la sirena
de vuelta al trabajo
muchos no volvieron
[Música]
tampoco manuel
te recuerdo amanda la calle more
corriendo a la fábrica
donde trabajaba
manuel
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]
y